(rush of wind)
- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems in the world.
I started the mentor
me series with the goal
to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by spending
more time with them
some of their mindset, their thoughts,
their beliefs, their attitudes,
their way of looking at
at the world seeps into us
to help up become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Nelson Mandela
and some of his best speeches.
Mentor me, Nelson.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as your watching
if somebody says something
that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat, inspirational music)
- I have fought very firmly
against white domination.
I have fought very firmly
against black domination.
I cherish the idea of a new South Africa
where all South Africans are equal.
For anybody who changes his principles
depending on whom he is dealing
that is not a man who can lead a nation.
(enthusiastic applause)
Apparently, Mr. Koppel,
you have not listened to my argument.
If you had done so,
then you have not been
serious in examining it.
I have replied to one of our friends here
that I have refused to be drawn
into the differences that exist
between various communities
inside the U.S.A.
You have not commented that
I'm going to offend anybody
by refusing to involve myself
in the internal affairs of the U.S.A.
(clears throat)
(applause)
Why are you so keen that
I should involve myself
in the internal affairs of Cuba and Libya?
- [Ted Koppel] No.
I expect you to be consistent.
I don't know if I've paralyzed you.
- No, no, no, no--
(raucous laughter and applause)
Alright.
I'm--
I'm afraid, Mr. Mandela,
that paralysis does not
set in quite that easily
in my case.
(laughter)
The point--
(applause)
- When I phoned some place in my country
and a lady answered the telephone,
I then asked "To whom am I speaking?"
She said, "you're speaking to me."
(laughter)
I said, "well, lady, I
know I'm speaking to you.
(laughter)
But what's your name?"
She said, "Who are you to ask for my name?
What's your name?"
(laughter)
I said, "Well, lady, as soon
as you tell me your name,
I'll tell you mine."
But as we argued as to who
should tell his or her name
she became very cross.
And she said, "you seem
to be a vapid person.
Have you passed your matric?"
Now matric in our country is a
university entry examination.
And I said, "well, lady,
you must be very careful.
Because if the qualification
to speak to you
is the possession of a matric certificate
I might work hard and pass my matric
and be in the same class as you are."
That was treason.
She said, "you will never be in my class."
And banged the telephone.
(laughter)
How I wish she were here today.
(laughter and enthusiastic applause)
She would now discover
that I have achieved more
than pass my matric.
The very right to be human
is denied every day
to hundreds of millions of people
as a result of poverty
and the unavailability
of basic necessities
such as food, jobs, water and shelter,
education, health care,
and a healthy environment.
As I sit in Qunu, my village,
and grow as ancient as it's hills,
I will continue to entertain the hope
that there has emerged a cadre of leaders
in my own country and region,
on my continent,
and in the world,
which will not allow that any
should be denied their freedom
as we were;
that any should be turned into refugees
that any should be condemned to go hungry
as we were;
that any should be stripped
of their human dignity
as we were.
- When you were convicted in 1964 for
conspiracy against the state.
And in your,
when you pleaded you said that,
"I am willing to die for this cause."
This is a very tough thing to say.
- Yes.
I had to say that.
Not from a spirit of bravado,
but because I genuinely felt
that they were going to hang us.
And it is the desire of
every freedom fighter,
to disappear under a cloud of glory
rather than that of fame.
It is the task of a freedom fighter,
when you see that the end
of your days has come,
to leave a tradition of
bravery, determination,
to face death for your principles.
And I thought about it.
It was not because I was brave.
But because one had a duty
to perform at that moment.
I have dedicated my life
to this struggle
of the African people.
I have fought against white domination.
And I have fought
against black domination.
I have cherished the ideal
of a democratic
and free society
in which all persons will
live together in harmony
and with equal opportunities.
It is an ideal for
which I hope to live for
and to see realized.
But my Lord, if it need be,
it is an ideal
for which I am prepared to die.
In 1993 I was walking along the street
when I met a couple of tourists
from a well known Western country.
And then the husband stopped and said,
"Mr. Mandela."
I said, "Many people
mistake me for that chap."
(laughter)
And he said, "Would I be entitled also
to mistake you for that chap?"
I say, "Well you'll be
doing what many people do."
He then turned to his wife and said,
"Darling, Mr. Mandela."
She was completely unimpressed.
(laughter)
And she said, "What is he famous for?"
And the husband, in his
embarrassment dropped the voice
and he said, "Mr. Mandela, Mr. Mandela."
(laughter)
And that the dear lady said,
"But I asked you what is he famous for?"
(laughter)
And without waiting for an
answer from the husband,
she turned to me and said,
"What are you famous for?"
(laughter)
I must confess, I couldn't
answer that question.
(laugher)
We are therefore pleased to announce
that we're able once again
to increase old age benefits.
(enthusiastic applause)
I'm very excited about this.
(laughter and applause)
Because in Davos in Switzerland
I told the plenary session
that in a few months, I'll
be standing next to the road,
saying, "Please help.
Unemployed.
No money.
A new wife."
(raucous laughter)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
What was your favorite clip and why?
What lesson are you going
to pull from this clip
and immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Anthony Avina from Anthony Avina Vlogs.
Anthony, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word
and doing that vlog review on it.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
- Today I'm going to be
reviewing a book for you guys
called Your One Word by Evan Carmichael.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(rush of wind)